build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people
this is bdp building these guys built a
quantum levitation track where a small
disc is suspended in the magnetic field
is locked inside this video is making
the rounds right now but we're
interested in how it works but this
becomes a superconductor when it's
cooled below negative 185 degrees
Celsius with liquid nitrogen
superconductors expel all magnetic field
from inside but since this is so thin
the field penetrates some creating these
things called flux tubes which traps the
disc in midair this is called Quantum
trapping find the link below for more
with a taxidermy borer and some choice
accessories downer created this awesome
bebop sculpture from Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles lego Milhouse meet Lego
Bart Lego Stewie meet Lego Darth Stewie
and a Dutch artist built this 45 foot
long sculpture in Brazil out of 10,000
flip-flops and it's called the fat
monkey drawed Keira Rathbone creates
typewriter art by strategically placing
letters numbers and symbols from the
typewriter instead of using brushstrokes
and crystal shay shows us how to
transfer a photograph onto a block of
wood basically cover the wood in gel
medium press it with a laser printed
picture wipe it off the next day code in
mod podge and it's done here's some
graffiti from a tumblr called Teenage
Mutant Ninja noses
[Music]
finally this guy recreates famous
paintings without lifting his pen here's
an ad for a pen showing his amazing
single stroke technique play it
the Chapman stick is a type of guitar
with up to 12 strings played by tapping
the strings and Bob Culbertson is a
master of it here he is from several
years back playing Beethoven's Fur Elise
in front of an interesting background
[Music]
Berrien covers the main theme from
requiem for a dream on harp
[Music]
and direct from Latvia is this video of
Metallica's nothing else matters played
on Lutz
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
funding another video from our favorite
Swedes for a song called ninja chips
it's a Lego animation made for brain
glass at planet of the apps in London
[Music]
submit your own be TPS at facebook.com
slash Vsauce gaming or through a
personal message here on YouTube and as
always thanks for watching